[Musique]
au groupe
lucas ça va quoi brancher pour rejoindre
la
balle juste comme ça la sortie
hockey et après le petit se braque
ok bon alors ça va cela me choque pas
fabregas et maintenant c'est la
poésie petit saut dessus là
moi je vais continuer ma route
on avec moi j'avais par là ok on va dire
je t'en prie
bêta ou non mais si le guerer maintenant
je vous fasse avec nos
jours
[Rires]
c'est pas possible
allez il est temps que nous les
citadines d'autres rayons à sa fille de
ça
mais ça
tue le ça est bien beau petit ordinateur
tu attends ça vient tout seul et ça va
plus vite qu'on pourrait le penser bah
si tu veux ramener la télé guyot des
mécènes au roi voilà
les
antennes
et le i
[Applaudissements]
wanna be chamonix f 16
jls